こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんは～、声、自分の声
気にしたことありますでしょうか？
人を形成するものは様々なものがあります
声、髪型、顔の形、体型
様々な要素があって初めて
その人というものがある
私は～、人の体の中で重要なパーツとして
声が、とても重要だと思いました。
声で結構イメージとかって変わるんですよ
もう声優さんとか、声でご飯を食べている人もいるぐらい
やっぱ、声っていうのはね人の中でも大事なものなんですけどもー！
ちょっと今回は！
あの僕いつも、こんななんか高くもなく低くもなく
何とも言えない声を出してるんですけども
こんな僕が！
もし、声が変わると！
どんな感じになるのかって
ちょっと純粋に思いました
なので、たぶんこの動画を見て
ちょっと、声の大事さとかが分かればいいなって思っているんで
ちょっと今日は
何気ない普段の生活をしてみたんですけども
僕の声だけを、ちょっと
トミックさんに今回やってもらいまして
トミックさんから何個か声の素材をもらったので
それをもとにちょっと動画をつくってみたので
今日の動画で、僕の声がトミックさんだったら
どんな感じになるのかっていうのをちょっとね
皆さんに聞いてもらいたいと思います
人の声が変わるだけで、どれくらい変化するのかと
では、どうぞ
♪～
うわーーーーー‼(トミックさんの声で)
ふー(トミックさんの声で)
ゴホン(トミックさんの声で)
今日も疲れたなー(トミックさんの声で)
よいしょーーー！(トミックさんの声で)
さーてインターネットでもするか(トミックさんの声で)
エロサイト、エロサイト♪(トミックさんの声で)
[キーボードを打つ音]
あ、その前にのどが渇いたなぁ(トミックさんの声で)
冷蔵庫に何か入ってるかなぁ(トミックさんの声で)
炭酸ランラン♪　炭酸ランラン♪　ランララランラン　　炭酸ラーン♪　(トミックさんの声で)
うわぁーーーーーーーーーーー‼(トミックさんの声で)
ゴホン(トミックさんの声で)
ごく…ごく…ごく…ごく…(トミックさんの声で)
うみゃーー(トミックさんの声で)
海の幸やでぇぇ～～(トミックさんの声で)
お！そうだ！(トミックさんの声で)
俺は、あれだ・・・(トミックさんの声で)
えーくしょん(くしゃみ（トミックさんの声で）)
[笑い]
自分で自分を殴る練習をしよう(トミックさんの声で)
えひ、えひ、おほー！(トミックさんの声で)
ぐぎゃじびぇー(トミックさんの声で)
♪～
【はじめしゃちょー】あぁ…惜しい
【はじめしゃちょー】炭酸ランラン♪　炭酸ランラン…
【はじめしゃちょー】ランララランラン炭酸ラーン♪　みたいな感じです
【トミックさん】[笑い]
【トミックさん】炭酸ランラン♪　炭酸ランラン♪　　　ランララランランラン…
【トミックさん】炭酸ラーン♪
【はじめしゃちょー】ちょっと違う！
【はじめしゃちょー】炭酸ランラン、炭酸ランラン、　ランララランラン炭酸ラーンです
【トミックさん】ランララランラン炭酸ラーン♪
【はじめしゃちょー】あ、完璧です。素晴らしいです
【はじめしゃちょー】え、もう録ります？
【トミックさん】もう録ってる
【はじめしゃちょー】あ、分かりました。じゃあ僕、静かにしてます
【トミックさん】うん
【トミックさん】ふーー今日も疲れたなぁ
【トミックさん】ゴホン
【トミックさん】よいしょーーー！
【トミックさん】さーて、インターネットでもするか
【トミックさん】さーて、エロサイト、エロサイト！
【トミックさん】炭酸ランラン♪　炭酸ランラン♪　　　ランララランラン炭酸ラーン♪
【トミックさん】ごく…ごく…ごく…ごく…
【トミックさん】うみゃーー！
【トミックさん】海の幸や
【トミックさん】えーくしょん(くしゃみ)
【トミックさん】うわぁーーーーーーーーーーーーー‼
【はじめしゃちょー】[笑い]